The Harvard Negotiating Project is a consortium of scholars from top U.S. universities.
The members work to improve the theory and practice of conflict resolution.
They came up with some basic negotiating rules.
The first is to identify the goal and not the position from which you start arguing,...
...because the latter may limit arriving at a solution that benefits both parties.
Any particular position is twofold, either you are successful or you are not.
Secondly, people often negotiate emotionally.
Then, you lose objectivity because you don't consider the other person's stance.
It is better to think of your opponent as a partner,...
...whom you work with, rather than against.
The third rule involves creativity.
Look at both parties' interests and arrive at options whereby everyone will be in a win-win situation.
You need to let go of personal standards and concentrate on objective ones that everyone can agree upon.